learning helps to get more command over
a subject
it also enhances your skill and
improvises your performance
in this day-to-day life the development
of software has grown much
and shown more impact all the knowledge
on development
comes from coding and programming so
we bring you some tips to learn and get
experience over coding and programming
without any difficulty hey everyone
welcome back to a whole new session from
simply learn
today we will be discussing about coding
or programming tips in this session
i will help you learn coding and
programming in a simple way
let us have a look for the agenda for
today's session
first we shall begin with understanding
what exactly does
the term coding means followed by that
we will understand
what is programming then we will get in
touch with learning the differences
between
coding and programming after that we
shall focus on discussing some important
tips to learn
programming and coding and finally we
will end our session by discussing the
benefits
however before we begin make sure that
you have subscribed to our youtube
channel and
don't forget to hit that bell icon so
that you can never miss an update from
simply learn
so without further ado let's get started
with our first topic
of this session what is coding
computer does not understand the human
language so in order to communicate with
the computer
we use some languages for communication
that requires
coding coding is a way of passing and
translating the instructions for
communication
with the computer moving forward let us
understand
what exactly programming means
programming is a process of designing
and building executable programs to work
on specific tasks
that involve analysis generation and
implementation of algorithms
many of the applications and development
involves and
uses programming this is all about
programming
now let's get started with learning some
differences between
coding and programming coding is a part
of programming
used to help in converting the language
into binary codes
which can be able to communicate with
the computer whereas
programming is a process that works on
creating specific tasks
according to the standards the next
difference is that
the coding is a basic step in
implementing the software
whereas programming deals in the depth
of the implementation and
dealing with complex problems coding
works with simple projects
which can be finished in a shorter
period whereas
programming deals with big projects and
possesses complete analysis in the
implementation of the projects
there are some fundamental differences
between coding and programming
now let's have a look at some of the
best tips
to learn programming or coding so some
of the best
tips to learn coding or programming are
practice
consistency in reading deep learning
jumping directly into the learning part
online resources for reference learning
how to debug a program
and finally to learn how to represent
your project
let's dive deep into these tips the
first one we have is
practice practice is the best way to
learn coding
or programming it takes a lot of time to
represent
but helps more in gaining knowledge when
you apply for a software job
there will be a technical round and they
will ask you to write some quotes
practicing helps you to clear those
rounds and get an opportunity to clear
those rounds
quite quickly it also improvises the
ability to identify the mistakes
by yourself the next we have is the
consistency in
reading the main problem in learning is
the consistency
when we work on our free time it doesn't
help much because of the power
of our brain going on working daily
helps to gain and boost up your
knowledge
and helps to think logically and improve
our skills
so we have to work every day to learn
coding
or programming the next tip of the
session
is deep learning when you get deeply
involved in the subject
we are learning it provides a way to
gain
more knowledge and attention over a
subject the deeper
we put in an effort the more we get back
it also helps us in improving our
thinking skills
it boosts the performance while
performing the tasks
the next step of the dot is jumping
directly into the learning phase
if you're going to learn something you
must start somewhere
it helps to predict and provide a
complete understanding of
upcoming topics if you are learning
coding or programming
you better start from the basics it
helps you more to grab the attention
over the subject
and improve your coding and programming
knowledge
and the next one we have is online
resources
one of the accessible sources of
learning programming or coding is the
online resources
there are plenty of online resources
like simplylearn and etc
these platforms are providing and
helping much in learning
they also offer free courses and videos
with the best concepts that you have
ever seen
my choice amongst most of the platforms
is simply learn
which helps you improve your coding
skills and moving forward the following
tips
we have the debugging making mistakes in
code and programming are
very common they are the key producers
of learning
so it is good to use debugging to
improve your coding or programming
skills
if you are good at debugging then
definitely you'll learn quite quickly
without any hassle and most importantly
the final tip of the session is
representing
representing the concept you learnt
plays a crucial part in learning
it may help to get more ideas and think
more profoundly about the subject
teaching someone discussing and sharing
will help to get more command over
coding and programming
so it is good to represent everything
that you learned
so these are a few tips to help you
learn coding or programming
now you have an idea of coding and
programming tips
now let us see some benefits of coding
or programming
coding or programming are playing a very
massive
role in present day-to-day life they are
showing the capacity to do anything
in the present let us see some of the
benefits of coding and programming
coding helps in improving presentation
skills developing creativity
helping in problem solving and teamwork
there are the best known benefits of
coding and programming
let us see some brief information about
the benefits of coding
and programming coding and programming
help in building self-confidence in a
person
while dealing with projects they are
helping in improving soft skills and
presentation skills
programming and coding also help in
improving creativity
while dealing with the applications and
projects they use much
creativity to develop those they require
a lot of creative knowledge
coding and programming also helps in
situations like problem solving
using these it is easy to find solutions
to complex problems
perfectly while working with the
project's required team
teamwork helps to gain more knowledge
and more experience
it also helps to improve communication
and project management skills
and this was all for today's session i
hope you guys found
it interesting and informative if you
have any questions
or queries then please let us know in
the comment sections below
our team of experts will be happy to
resolve all your queries until next time
thank you stay safe and keep learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
to nerd up and get certified
click here